pourquoi je dois changer ta présence au
sein de notre établissement fait peur à
tes camarades dégage
alors diu tu as eu des nouvelles de ton
vient audio si jamais ton vieux à tête
18 se rendre joyeux anniversaire ma
petite fille chérie papa
dites-moi qui l'a tuée je veux savoir on
n'a aucune piste rien que dalle [ __ ]
trouver le connard
vous êtes le chef du gang c'est bien ça
donc on ne t'aime plus que jamais je le
considérais comme un frère s'il vous
plaît aidez moi à trouver l'assassin si
tu veux vraiment venger la mort de ton
père d'abord tu vas devoir apprendre à
tuer celui qui a tué mon père est un
flic
haïti ne retient bien ce nom c'est le
tient à partir d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
le destin d'un chien et de suivre son
maître
vous la croyez vraiment des noms je lui
fais pas confiance d identité si une
guerre est déterrée avec danger ce qu'on
est obligé de choisir un camp
tu veux te venger c'est bien ça n'en a
rien à [ __ ] de moi ça j'ai encore deux
trois trucs avec lui après je rentre
promet
sert à rien que tu rentres des morts
pour moi
[Musique]